ouais presque n'importe quel film-- d'accord
désolé oui ça va bien c'est
bien parce qu'il y a le garde de l'autoroute ouais
ce matin supposons que maintenant c'est le
truc haagen qui tient ça fait toujours
sourire
ok chanceux tu es le prochain
alors nous passons  chaque façon de faire pour faire le
mien je peux aller avec ça et faire
algo incliner vers le haut Chuck d'accord
vecteur
pouvons-nous juste essayer par-dessus eux oh bien sûr
messieurs trafic centre-ville nourriture ouverte
guitare heure où les choses sont esto oh
ils le feront  la pluie sur le travail montre Oh
sur votre appareil photo encore peu d'attente jusqu'à ce que
nous dépassions ces codes 215 livres à venir
sur le wilshire et
inquiet pour le bébé
la réponse hein ceci à propos de cette inclinaison vers
le bas où vous pouvez simplement le terminer comme
ça  ils font juste les autres bâtiments
comme ça ouais ouais c'est un bon
processus d'accord de toute façon mais ça me rend heureux
je